en pleine nuit le quartier a été
réveillée en sursaut par l' incendie le
feu s'est déclaré dans une villa occupée
par des touristes
les corps de trois hommes deux femmes et
un enfants y ont été retrouvés sans vie
le maire adjoint de safran sont arrivés
sur les lieux un peu après les pompiers
est encore abasourdie les phocéens ont
été réveillés par une fumée à cette
résidence est ici même qu'ils se
trouvent les hauts de saint françois est
précisément les états du golfe
les pompiers ont été alertés pour une
fumée dans un appartement et donc moi
même aussi vers 3 heures du matin donc
je suis arrivé et puis on l'a constaté
qu'ils avaient six corps inanimé qui
étaient déjà décédés dans cette paisible
résidence du golf
les habitants eux aussi sont sous le
choc je suis sorti j'ai vu qui
effectivement il y avait la police la
voiture de la police de la gendarmerie
les pompiers et je me suis douté s'il se
passe quelque chose comme je suis à
l'état c'est pas très visible l'espace
n'était pas très visible pour moi donc
je suis descendu un petit peu j'ai
regardé et puis je me suis rendu compte
qu'il y avait quelque chose de
dramatique de brac qui se passait et
donc
dans ma vie je te dis qu'il ya eu un
incendie a eu des mots et il voilà quoi
j'ai pas pu aller plus loin parce que
l'accès était interdit
et puis bon mais du coup c'est quelque
chose qui est assez pénible à ces faits
dramatiques
deux autres villas ont été touchés par
l'incendié
mais aucune autre victime n'est à
déplorer il y avait deux côtés
cette personne précisément et 3 hot dogs
il ya des personnes qui ont été relogés
dans un hôtel pas loin l'identification
des victimes est en cours
la municipalité de saint françois se dit
prête à déclencher une cellule
psychologique pour les résidents et les
familles des victimes